[Applause]
joining him with the national clap for
carers but tonight the PM offering more
than just applause Forrest Johnson you
turning on his insistence that migrant
health workers pay a surcharge to use
the NHS now his government intends to
scrap the 400 pound fee no hint of that
yesterday does the Prime Minister think
that it's right that care workers coming
from abroad of working on our front line
should have to pay a surcharge of
hundreds sometimes thousands of pounds
to use the NHS themselves Prime Minister
well mr. speaker I've heard a great deal
about this like he might be in the
personal beneficiary of people who've
come from carers who've come from abroad
and frankly saved my life so I know
exactly the importance of what is but on
the other hand those contributions
actually help us to raise about 900
million pounds and it's very easy are
very difficult in the current
circumstances to find alternative
sources so with great respect to the
point that he makes I do think that that
is the right way forward just a day
later the health secretary dispatched to
deliver this news
the Prime Minister is asked the Home
Secretary and I to work on how we can
remove NHS and care workers from the NHS
surcharge as soon as possible and I'm
very pleased to be able to do that a win
for mr. Johnson's opposite number
yesterday he was clear he wasn't gonna
do this so he has u-turned but look it's
the right thing to do we can't clap our
carers on a Thursday and charge them to
use the NHS on a Friday but it wasn't
just labour pushing for change the PM's
hand falls by the threat of rebellion
from dozens of his own backbenchers the
Prime Minister has shown that he is
listened to everybody in the country
actually who wanted this change shown
that we care our party the government
care about the National Health Service
and this was an immoral tax in essence
and hitting the lowest-paid are people
who are risking their lives for
everybody on a daily basis this crisis
has changed our country
and what was a popular manifesto policy
just months ago now feels very out of
sync with public mood too u-turns in two
days
a reminder that the public's priorities
have changed and so too must the Prime
Minister's bathra be Sky News
Westminster